سأسافر أنا وفريقي إلى بكين
لحضور الألعاب الأولمبية الشتوية التي تقام بموجب
بعض الإجراءات المضادة الأكثر صرامة
في العالم ،
تبدأ رحلتنا قبل أسابيع من وجودي هنا في
طوكيو ، قبل 14 يومًا من موعد المباريات ، لكن
عليّ بالفعل تنزيل هذا
يبدأ تطبيق olympic health في تتبع صحتي
هنا كل يوم وتحميل شهادة اللقاح الخاصة بي ،
وأنا أحصل على بعض deja vu
باستخدام هذا التطبيق نظرًا لأننا اضطررنا إلى استخدام تطبيق
مشابه لألعاب طوكيو ولكن هذه
المرة أستخدم هاتفًا حارقًا بسبب
مخاوف الأمن السيبراني في الصين للأسبوعين
المقبلين ، أقوم بتقييد
التفاعلات الجسدية مع الآخرين بقدر
الإمكان قبل 96 ساعة من المغادرة ، هنا
نذهب لإجراء الاختبار الأول الخاص بي في المنزل ، وأقوم
بتحميل معلوماتي للحصول على
رمز الاستجابة السريعة الأخضر هذا
هنا نذهب
لقد هبطت للتو في بكين ، إنه أمر
سريالي تمامًا لم أعود إلى هنا منذ أن انتقلت منذ
حوالي عام ونصف ،
أول شيء رأيته أثناء مغادرتي
للطائرة
هو بحر من بدلات المواد الخطرة يبدو أشبه
بالذهاب  لمرفق طبي بخلاف
الطنين الأولمبي الذي تتوقعه من النزول
من الطائرة
الذي كان مؤلمًا للغاية ، لقد تلقيت للتو
اختبارًا في الأنف والحنجرة PCR
كنت أقوم بتمزيق قليلاً
، وقمت بإزالة الهجرة الجمركية وحصلت على شاري الأولمبي
دون رؤية وجه واحد
أنا رسميًا فيما يطلق عليه المنظمون
فقاعات الحلقة المغلقة المتعددة
المتصلة عن طريق النقل المخصص ،
والهدف هو إبقاء المشاركين الأولمبيين
منفصلين عن بقية الصين
أخيرًا في طريقي إلى الفندق على
متن هذه الحافلة الخاصة المخصصة فقط لنقل
المشاركين الأولمبيين.
فندق لديهم هذا الجدار
العملاق في
جميع أنحاء الفندق ، لذا لا يمكنك
الدخول والخروج بسهولة ،
فإن الموظفين المحليين هنا هم أيضًا جزء من
هذه الفقاعة ، وسيضطرون إلى الحجر الصحي
لمدة 21 يومًا قبل مغادرة الفقاعة
والعودة إلى منازلهم.  منازل في الصين ،
بكين لا تأخذ أي فرص
لقد تم إغلاق مجتمعات بأكملها في الصين
حتى لو كانت حالة واحدة مرغوبة
كنت أنتظر ست ساعات للتو تلقيت
الاتصال الخاص بي  لقد عادت بشكل سلبي ،
أنا مرتاح جدًا ولكن الأمر لم ينته بعد ، سأخضع
للاختبار يوميًا
وسأبقى في الغالب في هذه الغرفة والأماكن الأولمبية
طوال فترة إقامتي هنا